Let's pray together over day 24, Salvation Was,
Is, and Will Be.
Father, you are great and greatly to be praised.
I praise you for the scope of the salvation you have granted to us.
Lord, you have given us a salvation that is so much bigger than just some
eternal fire insurance.
It's so much greater than just something that happened a long ways back there at an
altar or beside our bed or in our car.
It's so much bigger than just one moment.
And Lord, we desire that the Holy Spirit would come upon us
with great power, and that you would accomplish the results,
the salvation that needs to be now.
Would you save us, Lord? Save us from sin and self.
We pray, Lord, that you would help us to be saved not in our
sins, but from our sins, and that would
include the power and presence of sin within
us. Lord, we ask that you would help us to not just be
saved from the consequences of our sin, but from the
presence and power of it. We know, Lord, that you can do something more with sin
than just forgive it. And we pray that this salvation that you have given to
us would not just be a past accomplished fact, but that it would be a living
present reality as Christ lives and rules and
reigns presently within us. The good news of his
kingdom come now. The good news of his
kingdom living in us now. As
the songwriter said, Lord, "We are called unto holiness.
Praise his dear name. This blessed secret to faith
now made plain. Not our own righteousness, but Christ
within, living and reigning and saving
from sin." Lord, do this ongoing work of saving with
us today, right now. Save us from self and
the consequences and the lasting results of Adam's
corruption within us. We pray that you'd do it in Jesus'
name.
Let's continue praying and seeking the Lord together.